.
Als ich ihm sagte,
ich sei aus der Schweiz,
verwechselte er sie
nicht mit Schweden.
Da war mir klar:
Er ist ein Guter.
Ich erzähle ihr immer Witze,
und ich erwarte eine Reaktion.
Aber da kommt jeweils nur:
"Ja, das war lustig."
Das stimmt,
ich lache nicht über seine Witze.
Ich sage ihm schon,
dass der Witz gut war,
aber ich muss nicht lachen.
Ich habe vieles für die Liebe
aufgegeben, eigentlich alles.
Freundin, Verlobte, Heirat.
# Forever you and me.
* Herzschlag *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Idyllische, südländisch
anmutende Gitarrenmusik *
Für die Liebe alles zurücklassen:
das Land, den Job, die Familie.
In "Hin und weg" erzählen wir
von Menschen, die genau das tun.
(Liebe fragt nicht nach dem Pass.)
(Und auch nicht danach,
ob man andere Pläne im Leben hatte.)
(Für eine funktionierende
binationale Liebe
braucht es radikale Entscheidungen.)
Ein Auto hat dafür gesorgt,
dass ein Spanier, Juan,
und eine Schweizerin, Simona,
zusammen in Italien leben -
allerdings nicht dieses hier.
Es war wohl Schicksal,
es musste so sein.
Ich sah Simona in einen Nachtklub.
Ich sprach sie an
und lud sie zu einem Drink ein.
Und da sind wir!
(Ich treffe Simona und Juan
in der Altstadt von Modena.)
Darf ich mich zu euch setzen?
- Sicher, sicher.
Ich bin Mona.
- Juan.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Hallo, Mona.
Und du bist Ella, nicht?
Und er heisst ...
- Wie heisst du?
Wie heisst du?
Cómo te llamas?
El no sabe.
(Der Formel-1-Rennstall von Ferrari
ist der Grund,
warum die beiden
in Norditalien gelandet sind.)
(Juan ist Maschineingenieur.)
(Er arbeitet in der Entwicklung
von Formel-1-Motoren.)
War es schon immer dein Traum,
für Ferrari zu arbeiten?
Oh ja, das ist so.
Einmal dort zu arbeiten,
schien mir eigentlich unmöglich.
Ferrari ist weltberühmt.
Schon in den Sommerferien
nach drei Jahren Beziehung
schwärmte er von Ferrari.
Damals war ich entschieden dagegen.
Später sagte ich,
er könne sich ja mal bewerben.
Ich wollte nicht immer
vorab Nein sagen.
Und dann bekam er diese Stelle.
Dann begannen wir,
intensiv zu diskutieren,
abzuwägen, zu überlegen
und Abschied zu nehmen.
"Will ich das oder nicht,
was will ich?"
Hast du dir auch überlegt,
nicht mitzugehen?- Ja.
Ich habe über alles nachgedacht.
Warum hast du dann doch
alles zurückgelassen
und bist für Juan und Ferrari
nach Modena gegangen?
Der ausschlaggebende Punkt war,
dass Juan sagte:
"Ich gehe nicht ohne dich -
nur mit dir."
Da wusste ich, dass er seinen Beruf
nicht über unsere Beziehung stellt.
Alleine wollte er nicht gehen -
nur, wenn ich mitkomme.
Das war ausschlaggebend,
dass ich mich
dafür entschieden habe.
(Kennengelernt haben sich die beiden
2010 in Paris.)
(Sie machte einen Sprachkurs
und er arbeitete
bei Renault als Ingenieur.)
(Über fünf Jahre lang
führten sie eine Fernbeziehung:
Olten - Paris und zurück.)
(Aber dann
kamen Italien und Ferrari ins Spiel.)
(An diesem Punkt
mussten sie sich entscheiden.)
Und wo?
Hier drinnen fragte mich Papa,
ob ich ihn heiraten wolle.
Er fragte mich auf Schweizerdeutsch:
"Willst du mich heiraten?"
* Zwei Männer unterhalten sich
auf Italienisch. *
* Ruhige Musik *
Er drückte einem Mann
die Kamera in die Hand.
Er sagte,
dieser Mann mache ein Foto von uns.
Eigentlich
machte dieser aber ein Video.
Dann wühlte er
in seiner Hosentasche.
Ich dachte: "Steh endlich für
das Foto hin, mach mal vorwärts!"
Ich fragte etwas genervt:
"Was machst du da?"
* Gefühlvoller Popsong:
"Take My Hand" von Adrian Stern
und Martin Villiger *
Als er auf die Knie ging,
dachte ich:
"Jetzt kommt ... Oh mein Gott!"
Er fragte mich:
"Willst du mich heiraten?"
# You just don't know
what the future ...
Erinnerst du dich noch,
was du genau gesagt hast?
Ich übte einige Tage lang im Voraus.
Ich fragte
Simonas Zwillingsschwester,
wie ich es aussprechen muss.
"Hurote ..."
- Wotsch ...
"Wotsch du hürote ..."
Ich erinnere mich
nicht mehr genau.
Ich musste mich
auf die bestmögliche Art verkaufen.
Ich dachte, auf Schweizerdeutsch
zu fragen, sei eine gute Idee.
Es hat geklappt.
Sie hat Ja gesagt.
Es freute mich natürlich,
als er schon am Freitag schrieb.
Er fragte, wo ich sei,
ob wir uns wiedersehen könnten.
Normalerweise
schreibt ein Mann nicht so früh.
Wenn er Sonntag sagt,
dann am Sonntag, nicht vorher.
Und als er dann schrieb,
freute ich mich natürlich.
* Lockere, heitere Musik *
Angefangen hat alles auf Tinder:
In den Ferien auf Hawaii
schaute Fabienne aus dem Glarnerland
sich auf der Dating-App um,
was für Männer
man hier treffen könnte.
Baby boy.
Und sie fand Francis.
Ich war hin und weg
von seinem Profilfoto auf Tinder.
Er sah so süss
auf diesem Bild aus.
Das zog mich an.
Es machte Klick.
Kann ich es sagen?
Oh no.
Kann ich?
Ich mochte ihr blondes Haar
und ihren Hintern.
Und es stimmte - neben Haar
und Hinterteil - auch der Humor.
* Lockere, heitere Musik *
Ich fragte ihn,
ob er an den Stand komme.
Bevor ich Fabienne traf,
konnte ich
gar nicht richtig schwimmen.
Wir gingen schnorcheln.
Ich hatte Angst, schwimmen zu gehen.
Um nicht unterzugehen,
kaufte ich mir ein BuggyBoard.
Er sagte mir nicht,
dass er Angst hat.
Ich wollte ihr natürlich
nicht zeigen, dass ich Angst hatte.
* Lockere, heitere Musik *
(Dass aus dieser Ferienromanze
mehr werden könnte,
war für Fabienne bald klar.)
(Ganz im Gegenteil zu Francis.)
(Trotz der schönen Zeit
sah er keine gemeinsame Zukunft.)
Als ich sie zum Flughafen brachte,
sagte ich ihr,
sie solle mich nicht mehr anrufen.
Sie aber meinte,
dass sie wiederkommen werde
und dass unsere Liebe
eine Chance hätte.
Als sie dann in der Schweiz war,
versuchte ich,
nicht an sie zu denken.
Es ging so weit,
dass ich sie nicht mehr anrief.
Ich wollte nicht wieder Liebeskummer
wegen einer Fernbeziehung haben.
Aber dann kam sie zurück,
und all die Gefühle
kamen wieder hoch.
Ich bin froh, dass sie zurück ist.
(Alles oder nichts
hiess es für Fabienne und Francis.)
(Und die beiden
setzten voll auf Risiko.)
(Knall auf Fall
verabschiedete sich Fabienne
vom Glarnerland
und ihrem Job als Sachbearbeiterin
und folgte ihrem Herzen.)
(Schon ein paar Monate später
heirateten sie.)
(Heute leben die beide
im Makiki-Viertel von Honolulu,
nur 10 Min. vom legendären
Waikiki-Strand entfernt.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
(Im helvetisch-hawaiianischen
Haushalt kocht v.a. Fabienne.)
(Für Francis lernte sie gar,
philippinische Spezialitäten
zuzubereiten.)
Lumpias - ich weiss,
die hat er vermisst.
Ich schlug das Rezept nach ...
... und habe es ausprobiert.
Und es scheint zu funktionieren.
(Lumpias
sind philippinische Frühlingsrollen.)
(Francis' Eltern sind Filipinos,
die in den 80er-Jahren
in die USA einwanderten.)
(Er selbst wurde auf Hawaii geboren.)
Sie sind schon so aufgewachsen,
dass die Mutter alles macht:
kochen, putzen, einkaufen.
Aber mit einem Italiener
wäre es wohl nicht anders gewesen -
da macht die Mutter auch alles.
Er hat sich auch sehr gebessert,
was das Helfen betrifft.
Sonst wäre ich
irgendwann davongelaufen.
Brauchst du meine Hilfe?
Lass uns an den Tisch gehen.
So, wer kann schneller und besser
Lumpias rollen?
Nein, das ist kein Wettbewerb.
Für mich ist es das erste Mal,
dass ich mit einer Partnerin
zusammenlebe.
Ich habe nie
mit einer Freundin zusammengelebt.
Für mich ist es auch das erste Mal.
Ich war oft auf Reisen.
Darum hatte wir immer
eine Frauen-WG mit Mami.
Das war eigentlich
am besten für mich.
Ich konnte verreisen,
wann ich wollte,
und es war immer jemand da,
der zur Wohnung schaute.
Die ist perfekt.
(In dieser Frauen-WG
der Familie Kaiser im Glarnerland
muss etwas Ansteckendes
im Umlauf gewesen sein.)
(Fabiennes jüngere Schwester
packte ein paar Monate später
auch die Koffer
und wanderte in die USA aus -
nach San Francisco.)
(Und auch sie: wegen der Liebe.)
Hey.
- Hallo, wie geht's?
Gut.
Es war heute nur etwas viel los,
aber ...
Was denn?
- Wie geht es Francis?
Er ist an seinem Mobiltelefon
und lernt Deutsch.
Matt hat das auch mal probiert,
aber nach einer Woche aufgegeben.
Matt muss vor Ort
im entsprechenden Land sein,
um eine Sprache zu lernen.
- Ja, so wie ich.
Also, dann noch einen schönen Abend.
Einen schönen Abend.
- Bis dann.
Tschau-tschau.
Seit wir nicht mehr zusammenwohnen,
ist unsere Beziehung
besser geworden.
Denn wir haben beide
einen sehr starken Charakter
und sind beide stur.
Sie ist halt die kleine Schwester.
Ich glaube, sie hat mehr Heimweh
nach dem Glarnerland als ich.
Irgendwie haben sie es erwartet,
aber sie waren schon recht traurig,
v.a. meine Mutter.
Sie hatte mich und meine Schwester
immer im Haus,
und dann gingen wir beide
Knall auf Fall.
Mit 21 sagte ich meinem Vater:
"Ich habe  d e n  Mann getroffen."
Und mein Vater:
"Du bist 21, er lebt weit entfernt."
"Der hat doch
bestimmt schon eine andere."
Und ich: "Nein, nein, nein."
(Eigentlich wollte Noëlle
nur ein wenig reisen.)
(Auf einem Roadtrip fuhr sie
der Westküste der USA entlang.)
(Doch dann nahm ihr Leben
eine dramatische Wende -
in einem hundsgewöhnlichen Irish Pub
in San Francisco.)
(Dort war Matt zu Besuch.)
(Und es war Liebe
auf den ersten Blick.)
Hi, buddy.
(Darum heisst ihr reinrassiger Corgi
auch Magners,
getauft nach dem irischen Cider,
dem Drink ihres ersten Dates.)
* Lockere Musik *
You did a good job.
You're looking very serious.
Schau dir diesen Wanderweg an!
Ich war während vier Monaten
nicht mehr hier.
Ganz ruhig, Magners.
Vorsicht, deine Brille.
Okay.
One, two and three.
(Anders als ihre Schwester Fabienne
liess sich Noëlle Zeit
mit dem Umzug.)
(Drei Jahre führten Matt und sie
eine Fernbeziehung.)
Letztes Mal
habe ich drei Wale gesehen.
Wow, ich habe hier
noch nie einen Wal gesehen.
Die waren da draussen.
Drei von ihnen,
zwei grosse und ein Baby.
(Erst verliebte sich Noëlle in Matt
und dann
in den kalifornischen Lifestyle.)
Das ist einer meiner Lieblingsorte.
Magners.
Ich liebe es,
dass hier alle Hundefanatiker sind.
Wie wir nutzen sie auch Instagram
wegen ihrer Hunde.
Sie positioniert ihn gerade
für ein Foto.
Das liebe ich.
- Das ist San Francisco.
Es ist wunderschön hier.
Man bekommt hier z.B. spontan
ein Kompliment wegen der Jacke,
ohne Hintergedanken.
Ich schätze das sehr,
denn ich bin auch so.
In der Schweiz sind die Menschen
unglaublich verklemmt.
Kennt man jemanden nicht,
redet man nicht miteinander.
Das fand ich immer ein wenig schade.
Natürlich,
es gibt es immer Probleme im Leben.
Aber die Liebe hilft bei allem,
da man alles teilen kann.
Ich habe noch nie jemanden
wie Matt getroffen.
Er hat ein riesengrosses Herz.
Er will immer,
dass es einem gut geht.
Er ist vielleicht
nicht so offen wie ich.
Er zeigt seine Gefühle
nicht so extrem wie ich.
Aber wenn er jemanden
ins Herz schliesst, dann für immer.
Ich habe so viele Dinge
von ihm gelernt,
die mir gar nicht bewusst waren.
Er machte mich
zu einem besseren Menschen.
* Sante Gitarrenklänge *
(Noëlle und Matt
mussten viele Klippen umschiffen,
um zusammen zu sein.)
(Was sie noch nicht wissen:
Ein grosser Test
steht ihnen kurz bevor.)
* Herzschlag *
(Zurück in die Schweiz.)
(Myriam
besucht ihre Eltern im Thurgau.)
(Normalerweise
lebt die 27-Jährige in Sambia.)
(Dort lernte sie auch
den Mann ihres Lebens kennen: Chris.)
(Und dieser kommt in ein paar Tagen
zum ersten Mal in die Schweiz.)
(Für beide ein wichtiger Schritt.)
(Eine Schweizerin und ein Sambier -
da prallen zwei völlig unter-
schiedliche Kulturen aufeinander.)
Für mich ist wichtig,
dass er erfährt,
wie es hier läuft, wie es aussieht,
wie die Menschen sind.
Er soll
meinen Hintergrund kennenlernen,
sehen, wo ich zur Schule ging,
was ich normalerweise esse.
Das war mit ein Grund
für unseren Besuch.
Wir warten jetzt noch
auf seine Ankunft.
Ich möchte ihm
mal meine Heimat zeigen
Sonst ist es immer er,
der mir seine Heimat zeigt.
Genau.
(Nach dem Wirtschaftsstudium
ging Myriam nach Afrika,
um einen humanitären Einsatz
zu leisten.)
(Weil ihr die Menschen und deren
Herzlichkeit zusagten, blieb sie.)
(In Kabwe, einer Stadt in Sambia,
fand sie eine Anstellung
bei einer NGO
und lernte Chris kennen.)
(Die beiden fackelten nicht lange.)
(Bald war klar,
dass sie zusammenbleiben wollen.)
Es war ein echt lustiger Moment,
als er mir den Antrag machte.
Ich war perplex,
ich rechnete nicht damit.
Ich umarmte ihn,
sagte sehr lange nichts.
* Herzschlag *
Nach ein paar Tränen
kam dann mein Ja.
Genau.
* Herzschlag *
Ausschlaggebend für den Antrag war,
dass er wusste,
dass ich in die Schweiz gehe.
Es war sehr unsicher,
ob er ein Visum bekommt,
wegen der speziellen Situation
mit Corona.
Vor meiner Abreise
wollte er noch die Sicherheit,
dass ich seine Frau bin.
Wir sind zwar beide noch jung,
aber ich wollte auch früh heiraten.
Für uns beide war klar,
dass wir füreinander geschaffen sind
und unser Leben
miteinander teilen wollen.
* Dynamische, metallische Musik *
(Über 10 Flugstunden entfernt,
in Pretoria,
wartet Chris auf das Besuchervisum
für die Schweiz.)
(Er musste deswegen extra
nach Südafrika reisen,
weil es in Sambia
keine Schweizer Botschaft gibt.)
Hallo.
- (Myriam) Hi.
How are you?
- Du siehst schön aus.
Thank you.
Die Behörde
hat die Dokumente angeschaut.
Wir werden das Visum
wohl morgen bekommen.
Gut. Dann können wir die Preise der
Flüge von Ende dieser Woche checken.
Und wir würden uns
Ende dieser Woche sehen.
Okay, baby. I love you.
(Seit anderthalb Jahren
sind sie ein Paar.)
(Es verging kaum ein Tag,
an dem sie sich nicht gesehen haben.)
Sie wiederzusehen,
wird ein magischer Moment sein.
Ich sehe mich im Zeitlupentempo
auf sie zu rennen und sie umarmen.
* Verspielte, hüpfende Klänge *
Sechs Wochen getrennt sein -
für eine junge Liebe
eine halbe Ewigkeit.
Ich griff auch in die Trickkiste.
Ich weiss noch,
dass ich sehr nervös war.
In der Schweiz
bedeutet es nicht so viel,
wenn man eine Partnerin
mit nach Hause nimmt.
Aber in Spanien stellt man nicht
jede Freundin den Eltern vor.
Ich dachte: "Oh mein Gott!"
Ich habe mir z.B. Wörter notiert,
die mich sympathisch
erscheinen lassen.
Ich notierte, wie man auf Spanisch
"Kann ich helfen?" sagt.
Ich dachte, es wäre super,
wenn ich mit seiner Mutter
in der Küche bin
und ich sie fragen kann:
"Kann ich helfen?"
Solche Dinge.
Das war schlau von mir.
Alles vorauszuplanen,
das ist typisch Simona.
Ich erinnere mich nicht exakt
an diese Situation ...
I was right.
Aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen,
dass es genau so war.
* Idyllische, südländisch
anmutende Gitarrenmusik *
(Bei den spanischen Schwiegereltern
funktionierte
dieser Trick jedenfalls.)
(Sie schlossen Simona ins Herz.)
(Mittlerweile
sind Simona und Juan selbst Eltern,
von Ella und Ian.)
(Ein spanischer Vater und eine
Schweizer Mutter in Italien.)
Willst du Fleisch?
- (Ian) Nein.
* Ian spricht spanisch. *
Das reicht, merci.
Süss. Je nach Ansprechperson
wechselt er die Sprache.
Ja, er switcht hin und her.
Er weiss, dass Papa kein Deutsch
und ich kein Spanisch verstehe -
zumindest meint er das.
Wieso unterhaltet
ihr euch auf Englisch?
Anfangs sprachen wir französisch,
weil wir uns in Paris kennenlernten.
Ich war dort,
um Französisch zu lernen.
Deshalb musste er mit mir
französisch sprechen.
Das wurde mit der Zeit schwierig.
Er fiel immer zurück ins Englisch
im Gespräch mit mir.
Und ich spreche zwar Französisch,
aber in dieser Sprache kann ich mich
nicht immer treffend ausdrücken.
* Ella schreit,
Ian äfft sie nach. *
Wechselt man die Sprache,
wird man zu einem anderen Menschen.
* Ian gibt heulende Laute von sich. *
- (Ella) Papá!
Papá?
Was wollt ihr?
Aufmerksamkeit.
Wenn man Kinder hat,
unterhält man sich nicht öfter.
Man hat eher weniger Zeit,
um sich zu unterhalten.
Wenn etwas dringend ist
oder die Kinder schreien,
ist es schwierig, in einer Fremd-
sprache auf den Punkt zu kommen.
(So viele Sprachen
bedeuten manchmal ein Durcheinander,
aber auch eine Chance, wenn man
als Kind so aufwachsen kann.)
Im besten Fall.
* Italienisches Chanson *
# Amore mio, ti amo.
(Schon in seiner Kindheit in Spanien
drehte sich bei Juan alles um Autos.)
(Und egal, wohin es ihn zieht,
seine Sammlung aus Büchern,
Modellautos und Erinnerungsstücken
muss mit.)
(Zuerst entwickelte er
Formel-1-Motoren für Renault,
jetzt für Ferrari.)
(In einer Vitrine
ist sein Autoaltar.)
So what is it here?
Hier habe ich
meine vielen Souvenirs,
Bilder und Unterschriften
von Fahrern.- Wow.
Darf Ian diese Sachen berühren?
Das darf er nicht, nein.
Noch nicht.
Das ist der Red Bull von 2010.
Zu dieser Zeit entwickelte Renault
den Motor für Red Bull.
Und wir haben mit diesem Modell
die Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen.
Wer war der Fahrer?
Sebastian Vettel.
Er wurde Weltmeister.
Und das?
Das ist der Motor. Und unser Team.
Ich habe schöne Erinnerungen
an diese Zeit.
Perfect timing!
Simona, was hat du
für ein Verhältnis zur Formel 1?
Ein gespaltenes.
Nein, für mich ist es okay,
es ist seine Leidenschaft.
Da wir zusammen sind,
spielt die Formel 1
auch eine Rolle in meinem Leben.
Er schaut Rennen ...
und ich müsste nicht mit schauen.
Aber ich finde es ...
Es ist okay.
Auch wenn es nicht
die eigene Leidenschaft ist,
sollte man sich zumindest ein wenig
für die Leidenschaft des anderen
interessieren.
Eines Tages kam Simona und sagte,
sie hätte ein Geschenk für mich.
Sie gab mir
diesen kleinen Ferrari California,
einen der kleinsten Ferraris,
die es gibt.
Und sie gab mir auch dieses Armband.
"Ein kleiner Ferrari
ist auf dem Weg."
Ich schaute sie an und fragte:
"Bist du schwanger?"
Sie sagte: "Ja."
It was actually
"little Ferrari on the road".
Sie verstand meine Sprache,
und sie machte mich sehr glücklich.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
(Juan fand bei Ferrari
seinen Traumjob.)
(Und Simona?)
(Eigentlich ist sie Ergotherapeutin.)
(Aber in Italien ihren Beruf
auszuüben, ist schwierig.)
(Das Schweizer Diplom
wird nicht voll anerkannt.)
(Darum gründete sie im Land der Mode
ihr eigenes kleines Label.)
(Sie näht Kinderkleider.)
An Ideen fehlt es mir nicht,
wie man das Ganze erweitern
und zu mehr Kunden kommen könnte.
Aber mit den Kindern
fehlt mir die Zeit dazu.
Als ich im ersten Jahr hier war
und meinen Beruf nicht mehr
ausüben konnte, merkte ich,
wie stark ich mich
mit dieser Rolle identifiziere:
Ich fühlte mich als Ergotherapeutin.
Und hier war ich
nicht mehr Ergotherapeutin,
sondern die Freundin eines Mannes,
der bei Ferrari arbeitet.
Mit dem Muttersein
fand ich dann eine neue Rolle.
Ich wollte sowieso
eine Familie gründen, Mutter sein.
Da ich schon seit fünf Jahren
meinem Beruf nicht mehr nachgehe,
habe ich schon fast vergessen,
dass ich mal Ergotherapeutin war,
obwohl ich den Beruf geliebt habe.
(Trotzdem
hat Simona im Alltag oft Mühe
mit der klassischen
Rollenverteilung.)
(Auch wenn die Liebe gross ist:
Es ist ein hoher Preis,
die Familie, die Karriere
und den Beruf zurückzulassen.)
(Simonas Freundinnen
kennen das aus eigener Erfahrung.)
(Auch sie landeten
ihrer Männer wegen in Modena.)
Hi. Hi.
How good to see you.
Hi. Hello.
I'm Mona. Nice to meet you.
- Hi, Mona.
Nice to meet you. Lilia.
I'm Sarah. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
(Gastgeberin Lilia
stammt von den Färöerinseln.)
(Die Klimawissenschaftlerin
lebt seit drei Jahren in Modena.)
(Sarah aus Neuseeland verliebte sich
beim Reisen in einen Italiener.)
(Ob mit oder ohne Kinder,
mindestens einmal pro Woche
treffen sich die drei Freundinnen.)
Warum ist es wichtig,
Freundinnen
mit der gleichen Erfahrung zu haben?
What are you talking about,
what are you sharing?
Wir sind in der gleichen Situation
und wissen, wie es ist,
in einem fremden Land zu leben,
mit all seinen Herausforderungen.
Auch dass wir Mütter sind,
verbindet uns.
Wir wissen, wie es sich anfühlt,
wenn man einen schwierigen Tag hatte
und traurig ist
und man am liebsten
daheim bei seiner Familie wäre.
Aber dann ist man in Italien.
Unsere Freundschaft
hilft über starkes Heimweh hinweg.
It's a bit family.
- Yeah.
Wir sind eine Art Familie,
und wir lachen
auch sehr viel miteinander.
In unserer Sendung
ist es mehrheitlich so,
dass die Frau ihr Land
für den Mann verlässt.
Warum ist das so?
Wenn man
aus unterschiedlichen Ländern kommt,
muss man sich für eines entscheiden.
Einer ist doch immer
ein bisschen unglücklich.
Oder musste
das grössere Opfer bringen.
Alexis würde nie
auf den Färöerinseln leben wollen.
Die sind so klein -
ich habe ihn gar nicht erst gefragt.
* Lachen *
Meiner
ist ein richtiges Muttersöhnchen.
Er liebt seine Mutter,
ihm ist es wohl hier.
Ich bin viel abenteuerlustiger
und anpassungsfähiger.
Er ist das Gegenteil.
Ich entschloss mich,
hierherzukommen.
Für ihn
wäre es wohl schwierig gewesen,
in Neuseeland eine Arbeit
als Buchhalter zu finden.
Irgendwie ist es
immer noch das alte Frauenbild:
Die Frau zieht die Kinder auf und
arbeitet nebenher noch ein wenig.
Sie kann ja
überall irgendetwas finden.
Es ist der Mann, der entscheidet,
sein Job. Immer noch.
Frauen,
wir sollten das jetzt ändern.
Ja,
das ist eine grosse Herausforderung.
* Herzschlag *
# Take my hand.
Jetzt ist es so weit.
- Ja.
(Die ganze Familie Ziörjen
reiste aus dem Thurgau an,
um Chris aus Sambia zu empfangen,
Myriams zukünftigen Ehemann.)
Es ist noch relativ unwirklich.
Ich merke es wohl erst,
wenn er da ist.
Ist das Vollrahm?
Ja, für die Thurgauer Süssmostcreme.
(Myriam)
Er mag weder Schokolade noch Käse.
Das wird er mir zu Hause
nicht wegessen.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt
schon etwas nervös.
Wir waren drei Wochen in Sambia,
unternahmen dort eine Reise.
Er war zeitweise mit dabei,
und wir sahen, wo er lebt.
Es ist vollkommen anders.
Wir haben alles,
leben vergleichsweise sehr luxuriös.
Was für uns selbstverständlich ist,
ist es für sie nicht.
Ich bin - ehrlich gesagt -
ziemlich verunsichert,
wie ich damit umgehen soll.
Unser zukünftiger Schwiegersohn -
jetzt geht's los.
Er fragte, ob er sie heiraten dürfe,
hielt um ihre Hand an.
Ich sagte Ja.
Ich kannte ihn ja,
weil wir dort waren.
Ich kenne auch Myriam.
Ihr ist es ernst damit,
die beiden lieben sich.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Ihr wusstet es vor mir.
- Ja, ich wusste es vor dir.
(Chris reist zum ersten Mal überhaupt
nach Europa.)
* Herzschlag *
Unsere Geduld
wird auf die Probe gestellt.
Zumal alle anderen
schon abgeholt wurden.
Sie wurden abgeholt,
es ist wieder leer.
Ist er überhaupt in diesem Flieger?
- Das werden wir sehen.
Hoffen wir mal das Beste.
* Herzschlag *
* Erfreuter Aufschrei *
Hi.
Are we allowed to hug?
- What took you so long?
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
And honestly, everybody
was gone already.- Really?
Hi. Welcome.
- Thank you.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
How are you?
- Okay. Thank you, thank you.
I missed you.
- I missed you too.
Finally you're here.
I am here, so I am like:
Gott sei Dank!
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
(Chris) Es ist kalt.
Die Schweiz ist kalt.
Und es ist grün, das ist schön.
Ich es kaum erwarten, wie mich
die Schweiz überraschen wird.
Aber es ist wirklich kalt.
I can feel it.
(Gut zwei Monate
bleibt Chris in der Schweiz.)
Very, very welcome.
- Danke schön.
Our home is your home.
Now, I'm here.
Bist du schon hungrig,
oder bist du müde?
Beides.
Tired and hungry?
- Tired and hungry for coffee.
Einen Kaffee?
Das kannst du haben.
Ja, das sind wir.
Ich sah Myriam
zum ersten Mal in Sambia,
als sie bei unserer Organisation
zu arbeiten begann.
Ich dachte, sie sei verheiratet,
weil sie einen Ring trug.
"Also noch eine verheiratete Frau,
die bei uns arbeitet", dachte ich.
Aber dann, bei einem Basketball-
spiel, begannen wir zu reden,
und ich realisierte,
dass sie unverheiratet war.
Das war der Anfang
unserer Liebesgeschichte.
So.
Ich habe dir wenig Rösti gegeben,
weil du keinen Käse magst.
En Guete miteinander.
- En Guete.- En Guete.
(Chris) En Guete.
Hu!
Das schmeckt gut -
sogar sehr gut.
That's good.
Bei unserem ersten Treffen warst du
sehr nervös. Nicht wahr, Chris?
Ja.
Oh ja, ich war sehr nervös,
geradezu ängstlich.
Myriam ist die erste Frau, die ich
meiner Mutter vorgestellt habe.
Denn ich wollte ihr
nur die Frau vorstellen,
mit der ich zusammenbleiben will.
Da Myriam
eine wunderbare Person ist,
hatte meine Mutter
auch keine Bedenken.
Sie freut sich sehr.
Ja, sie war offen
und hat mich gut aufgenommen.
* Herzschlag *
Ich hatte schon immer das Gefühl,
dass ich irgendwann
jemanden kennenlernen würde,
der nicht in der Schweiz lebt.
Wolltest du nicht jemanden,
der Spanisch spricht?- No.
Ich wusste,
dass du auf einem Roadtrip warst.
Ich wusste aber nicht, dass du
am anderen Ende der Welt lebst.
Ich dachte,
vielleicht lebst du in Los Angeles.
Das ist nicht so weit weg,
da kann man hinfahren.
Aber als du sagtest,
es sei die Schweiz,
da dachte ich: "Oh ... Oh Mann."
* Lockere Musik *
(San Francisco - Schweiz,
über 9'000 km Distanz.)
(Einmal über den Atlantik
und quer durch die USA.)
(Dass sie zusammengehören,
wussten beide schnell.)
(Aber auch etwas anderes
war Noëlle klar:
Sie wollte nicht Hals über Kopf
alles zurücklassen.)
(Mit 21 hatte sie eben
ihre Ausbildung abgeschlossen
und wollte erst einmal
Berufserfahrung sammeln.)
(Die Konsequenz:
eine dreijährige Fernbeziehung.)
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
(Flüsternd) Hey. There you go.
- Thank you.
Wenn er ein Meeting hat,
muss ich mich reinschleichen
und darauf achten,
dass mich niemand sieht.
Hi, buddy.
(Noëlle machte in der Schweiz
eine Ausbildung zur Kindergärtnerin.)
It's okay, buddy.
Ich sagte Matt,
dass ich nur komme,
wenn ich meinen Beruf ausüben kann.
Dafür ging ich zur Schule.
Ich wollte mit Kindern arbeiten
und ein eigenes Visum haben,
um nicht abhängig von Matt zu sein.
Ich finde, so lastet weniger Druck
auf unserer Beziehung.
Meine Schule hier in San Francisco
ist die einzige,
die auch Visa ausstellen darf.
Das war eigentlich
meine einzige Chance.
Ich bewarb mich,
und zum Glück hat es geklappt.
Hallo, Anna.
Hey, Alba.
Anna und Alba,
eure Kameras sind aus.
Vielleicht könnt ihr
sie wieder einschalten.
Sehr schön - alle hier.
Schaut mal, Magners ist auch hier.
Magners und Whoopie
sind jetzt beste Freunde.
Whoopie, wie geht es dir denn heute?
(Sie unterrichtet
in einer deutschsprachigen Schule -
jetzt, während des Shutdowns,
von zu Hause aus.)
Geht es dir ta-tü-ta-ta, Whoopie?
(Verfremdete Stimme)
Ta-tü-ta-ta, ta-tü-ta-ta.
Pst!
Das heisst ruhig sein.
Nicht wahr, Whoopie?
Nein, du musst dich jetzt nicht ...
Er wollte sich verstecken.
* Aufschrei, Lachen *
Habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Mach keinen Quatsch, Coco. Komm her!
Coco ...
Nee, der macht nur Quatsch. Coco!
* Die Kinder lachen. *
Er flog mit dem Kopf nach unten.
Coco, komm mal her.
Komm mal her.
(Mädchen) Du bist ein süsses Ding.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Tschüss, Jakob.
- Tschüss.
Tschüss.
(Der strenge Shutdown in Kalifornien
bereitet
der 27-Jährigen grosse Mühe.)
(Weil sie eingeschränkt ist
und kaum mehr jemanden treffen kann.)
(Noëlle vermisst die Schweiz
je länger desto mehr.)
Ich habe einen sehr engen Kontakt zu
meinen Freunden und meiner Familie.
Wenn ich sie länger nicht treffe,
werde ich fast ein wenig depressiv.
Ja.
(Das Heimweh
plagt Noëlle immer wieder.)
(Matt schenkte ihr deshalb
ein Stück Heimat zum Aufhängen.)
Das bekam ich zu Weihnachten.
Das ist der Klöntalersee -
das war megasüss.
Ja.
(Ablenkung ist Matts Strategie,
wenn das Heimweh stärker wird.)
That was super good.
Dann gehen wir
für gewöhnlich in die Berge,
die den Schweizer Bergen
am ähnlichsten sind,
z.B. Lake Tahoe.
Es ist zwar nicht die Schweiz -
trotzdem hilft es manchmal.
* Melancholische Klänge, Herzschlag *
(Aber das Heimweh siegt.)
(Durchsage) Netstal.
(In der nächsten Folge
kehrt Noëlle zurück in die Schweiz
und überrascht ihre Mutter.)
* Aufschrei *
Es ist okay.
Oh nein, was machst du hier?
(Die Freude in der alten Heimat
ist aber kurz.)
Am Mittwoch war mein Pass
im Briefkasten mit einer Absage.
Mein Visumsantrag wurde abgelehnt.
- Echt?- Ja.
(Sie kann nicht zurück in die USA.)
(Schluchzend)
Ich habe Angst, alles zu verlieren.
(Matt)
Nein, du kannst uns nicht verlieren.
(Einfacher ist es
bei ihrer Schwester Fabienne.)
(Sie hat bereits ihre Greencard.)
(Dafür musst sie
explizite Antworten liefern.)
Ich wurde z.B. gefragt,
ob wir Safer Sex praktizieren.
(Bei Ferrari
fand Juan seinen Traumjob.)
(Doch für Simona ist klar, dass sie
nicht ewig in Italien leben will.)
Ich ging als Erste
einen Kompromiss ein.
Nun ist er an der Reihe -
vielleicht zurück in die Schweiz?
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
# Take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2021